(beep)
(operatic music)
(garage door opens)
- My name is Shintaro Okamoto.
I'm the founder and creative director of
Okamoto Studio Custom Ice.
Coors Light asked me and
my team to think about
what different, unique
things we do with ice
and I wanted to really kind of
focus on the freezing process itself.
Right now I'm sitting in my freezer,
here in my studio in Queens, New York.
(classical music)
I always say not all Alaskans
played with ice, but I did.
I started carving ice
with my father, I think,
when I was, maybe 12-13.
That's when my father first
entered an international
ice carving competition that
the city of Anchorage hosted.
And I was his partner.
It was a really terrible experience.
My job was shoveling snow
and scrap ice all night
but at the end the
sculpture was beautiful,
the response was amazing.
It was a really beautiful
thing that I really kinda
fell in love with.
(water spraying)
Trying to get rid of
any kind of excess soil.
Oh boy, it's gonna be really tricky.
(tools clink)
Oh, I lost my ring.
I thought this was going to be easy.
This is gonna suck.
Nope.
Screen, screen.
(playful music)
Change of plan.
Plan A didn't work, plan B didn't work,
plan C I think is brilliant.
If it works.
Don't touch it, I don't
wanna do it, re-do it.
(laughs)
I've always seen ice as
a time-based material.
It's constantly changing, evolving.
It's that kind of
embodiment of time passing.
Freezing items inside the ice
does almost exact opposite.
Where we stop the time.
(train rumbles)
All right so the ice's been
freezing since yesterday.
So it grew quite a lot last night,
it was nice and cool I guess.
(chain clanking)
That looks great.
(scraping)
(chain clanks)
We really work with
the moments of freezing
and studying the process
of how ice is formed
and how ice itself really
kind of comes to life.
(saw whirs)
(scraping)
(soft music)
There's a really beautiful
dichotomy of the cold
trapping the best of
the summer within ice.
(match strikes)
I think my father is
really chuckling every day
with the different kind
of things that we do
and challenges we face.
It's him who really got me into ice.
And it's often frustrating,
cold,
not the most comfortable
things to work with
but the end result
is always mesmerizing
and I'm always looking for
something fun to do everyday.
(soft music)